[MUSIC PLAYING]
BELLA FITZPATRICK: Thank
you so much for coming.
I can't believe I am more
popular than Irish sun.
That is bizarre.
That's so weird.
No, really,
genuinely, thank you.
This is [? deadly. ?]
I asked to have a stool
so I could feel like
a '90s stand up comic.
What's the deal with
airplane food, right?
So yeah, thanks for having me.
My name's Bella FitzPatrick.
I used the "she"
and "her" pronouns.
If you don't know
what that means,
that just means that's
how you refer to me later.
So you'd say, Bella, she
talked to us about ShoutOut.
She was nice.
I hope you say this.
If you used other
pronouns for me,
that would hurt my feelings.
If you're thinking it's very
obvious that we would call
you she and her, thank you.
I'm trying to look
like a woman, so I'm
glad that I'm
succeeding, if I am.
But in the LGBT
community, we just
don't make these
types of assumptions.
You wouldn't know
that I didn't have
other pronouns such as "they"
and "them" or something
like that.
So we just take all
the guesswork out,
put it right there, put it in
our email signatures and stuff
like that.
So that's why that's there,
in case anybody was wondering.
That's our-- oh, no.
I haven't done the thing.
Oh, yeah.
That would make
more sense there.
Yeah.
So that's our Twitter
handle and our Facebook.
And that's my personal
Twitter handle.
If you have a good time
today, I would really
appreciate if you'd shout out,
as it were, about it online.
And if you don't have a good
time, don't tell anybody.
Don't tweet about it.
Just keep that to yourself if
you don't have a good time.
So I'm just going to try to talk
to you a bit about what we do
and how we do it.
And this is, like,
the first time
I've given this type of talk
at all, so just bear with me.
[GROWLS] That's a gay joke.
Bears.
No?
OK.
Never mind.
Cool.
So this is just some of
our stats from this year.
Our primary activity is
giving workshops in schools
with students to
tackle LGBT bullying
in schools in the classroom.
We did a lot this year.
We did 349 workshops.
They were all free for schools.
That means we've reached
about 10,000 students face
to face, in their
classroom, talking to them,
being queer and talking
to them, or being an ally
and talking to them.
So that's [? deadly. ?] I'm
really, really appreciative.
I did not do all
of these workshops.
These were done by 61
incredible, amazing volunteers
that we just wouldn't
operate without-- so just
appreciate them so much.
This happened across 102
schools in 22 counties, which
means that there are
still more counties
to do and still more
schools to get to,
but we're getting there.
We work in Northern
Ireland as well,
so this includes all of
the counties of the island.
Yeah.
So this is kind of what
our growth looks like.
I guess if this was your
stock, you'd be pretty pleased.
Yeah, we're pretty pleased.
We started off with doing, like,
10 workshops the pilot year.
And the workshop
wasn't much more
of us just going into schools
and being, like, we're LGBT!
That's it.
But then we developed
a really specific
anti-bullying workshop.
Then we did 30, around 40,
90, 150, 171, and at 349.
So yeah, chuffed with that.
I got hired here.
Not to brag, but--
because before that, we
were entirely voluntary.
Completely.
We had no staff at all.
We were just a bunch of friends.
We were just a
Facebook group just
getting in touch with schools,
going there whenever we could.
And then we got
one staff member,
and you're looking at her.
So I have pretty wild
staff parties on my own.
Yeah.
It can be lonely, but it's
still like a dream come true
because I've been working for
free for ShoutOut for so long.
And I always had
a day job, which
I was always rubbish
at, right, because I
had this other passion.
I was constantly leaving.
And I was just so lucky that I
had a day job that was really
like respectful of that.
They were always like,
where are you going, Bella?
Something gay, is it?
And I'd be like, yes.
I won't be in till 12:00, sorry.
Yeah.
So that growth there, that's
not about me, specifically.
That's just what happens
when you can have staff.
This is a similar story
for tech startups.
You might have an idea
working at the weekends.
And once you commit
your full time to it,
you just see this growth, and
it's really, really amazing.
I'm also only part time,
so this is 20 hours a week.
Imagine what we would do
with two staff members.
God.
It'd be mad.
So yeah, it's just been a
really incredible journey.
It's important to know
we're doing this in Ireland,
on the island of Ireland, which
is a very interesting place
to be talking about
LGBTQIAP stuff.
Because we're just a funny
little country, aren't we?
It's like a funny little
teddy bear-shaped country.
We have a lot of good stuff.
We have a lot of
good equalities.
But legal equality does
not equal social equality.
So we got a lot of
good legislation.
It's 25 years since
decriminalization
of homosexuality between men.
So that means before 25 years,
that you could go to jail,
and people did.
Men did go to jail for
holding hands, for kissing.
And now we have
marriage equality,
and we have gender recognition.
Hands up, who was in Ireland
for the marriage equality
referendum?
OK, loads of you.
So you kind of knew
what it was like.
It was tough because begging
people for your rights
is not an ideal way
to spend a Saturday.
But that's what we did.
It has not done what
people think it has done.
It really, it just hasn't.
People think it is
representative of an expansion
of tolerance, and it just isn't.
What we put forward in the
marriage equality referendum
was an extremely limited view
of LGBT people and LGBT culture.
So it was very much just
like, we're were two white,
able-bodied lads,
and we work in KPMG.
And we just want to watch "The
Late Late" and have a pint
and get married, woo!
And I mean, there's nothing
wrong with any of those things.
Working at KPMG, that's fine.
Having a pint is fine.
Watching "The Late Late"--
well, that's not so fine.
But people have their own thing.
So really, people's ideas
didn't really expand.
People's tolerance
didn't expand,
so much as we tricked them into
thinking we were they already
tolerated.
And that means we haven't
seen the movement in schools
that you would
think we would see
in a post-marriage
referendum Ireland.
We have not seen that
much greater acceptance.
I've done workshops in schools
before marriage equality,
and I've done workshops in
schools post-marriage equality.
And it is different.
It is not better.
If you are a charismatic,
macho gay lad--
yeah, you might get on
a little bit better.
If you are a feminine,
charismatic, popular gay girl,
you might get on a
little bit better.
But if you go
against gender norms,
it's still a very, very
tough place to be in Ireland.
I've actually heard, in schools,
teachers say things like,
you can't help being gay, but
you can help being a faggot.
And that's kind of where
we're at at the moment.
And you kind of see
that around Pride.
You see that a lot.
Why are they marching?
They have marriage equality.
Why are they going
out on the streets
making a show of themselves?
Why do they have
to be like that?
Why can't they just be normal?
There's this whole idea
that the ultimate goal
of the LGBT community
is to assimilate
into a cis,
heteronormative mainstream.
And that's just not the case.
We just want to be tolerated,
want to be celebrated,
and we want to be accepted.
So there's a little
bit of complacency
in post-marriage
referendum Ireland
about the social equality
and the legal equality piece.
We also have gender
recognition--
some of the best in the world.
You can change your gender on
your passport and your birth
cert and all your
gender markers,
and it doesn't require
any medical intervention.
It is a self-declaration.
It is a declaration
you make yourself
without any other input.
And that's incredible.
It really, really is.
But how can that impact
schools when we never talk
about LGBT people in schools?
It never comes up.
These laws pertain to adults.
So it has not done
what we need it
to do for our younger people.
So our whole point
of ShoutOut is
to get cis and
straight young people
and those who work with young
people to be OK with this.
The classic, you know?
We hear a lot of, like, they
keep on adding on letters.
I suppose we do, but what of it?
People want to know,
what is the actual one?
What's the right one,
as if there's some
sort of central committee?
I'll bring it up at
the next big meeting.
This is the one we use
because it's inclusive.
It works.
It's terrible for
a poster, but--
it doesn't have as much brand
recognition, but look it.
It's all about getting people
to listen to us about this
and not interrupt us with
statements like, I just
think people are people,
and aren't labels bad?
These are, like, our two
most hated things to say.
Of course, we put
ourself in the position
to answer that question.
I'm not saying I'm mad that
you've asked that question.
I'm just saying, when you
hear it loads of times,
you begin to hate it.
"I just treat
people as people" is
the ultimate hand-washing
statement anybody
could ever say that
essentially means,
I don't have to learn
about this, because I just
treat people like people.
What does that even mean?
"I just treat
people like people."
Good.
You don't treat them like
dogs or donkeys or whatever.
You should treat
people like people.
That doesn't exclude
you from needing
to know about how you are
part of systematic oppression.
You are, and I am, and we
all are in different ways,
depending on our
privileges, depending
on how we conduct ourselves.
And that type of sentiment, "I
just treat people like people,"
is not pertaining only
to the LGBT community,
but different cultures and
different religions and women.
And it's just ultimately
said to shake off this idea
that you have any
responsibility.
So yeah-- not a big
fan of that sentiment.
And labels being bad--
we get this a lot.
Labels are bad.
We're actually a big fan
of labels in the community.
I don't know if you've
seen all the letters,
but yeah, we like it.
I think labels are bad if
labels have never served you.
If you've never needed
to be defined by a label,
if you are the majority
person in your community,
then you've never
realized how labels
can be good, because you've
only seen labels limiting you.
You've only seen them
ever hindering you,
who you are, in the sense that--
men just used to be
men, and now, they're
cis, straight, white men.
And they don't like that at all.
But we love labels because
when you're a minority,
it helps you find
your community,
helps you find people who've
had similar experiences to you.
And that is really, really,
really a survival tactic.
So if we could do
away with labels,
then we'd do away
with our community.
Is the ultimate goal maybe
to get rid of labels?
Sure, OK, maybe.
We're not there
yet, not even close.
But maybe we'll create a
critical mass of labels,
and they'll all, like,
implode in on each other.
Maybe that's the goal.
I don't know.
All right.
Let's see what you guys know.
All right-- L.
AUDIENCE: [? Lesbians. ?]
BELLA FITZPATRICK:
That was pitiful.
It's Pride Week--
(whispered) Fuck's sake.
L.
AUDIENCE: Lesbians.
BELLA FITZPATRICK: There we go.
OK, much better.
G.
AUDIENCE: Gay.
BELLA FITZPATRICK: B.
AUDIENCE: Bisexual.
BELLA FITZPATRICK: T.
AUDIENCE: Transgender.
BELLA FITZPATRICK:
[LAUGHS] Oh, ho.
Let's do a little poll,
a little referendum.
God, we love a referendum.
Hands up for transgender?
Hands up for transsexual?
Do people say other
things as well?
AUDIENCE: Trans.
BELLA FITZPATRICK:
Trans, yeah, yeah.
Hands up for trans, then?
OK.
Oh, a very split room.
OK, cool.
It's transgender or trans.
"Trans" is just short
for transgender.
It's not transsexual, OK?
It's not.
And this is good you guys know
because, of course, being woke
is a hierarchy.
And you all need to level up.
You'll level up
with me now today.
"Transsexual" is fallen out
of favor by the community.
We don't really
use it that much.
But there is a golden rule,
numero uno, the first rule
of queer club is
talk about queer club
so everyone knows
about it, and we
can get more people involved.
No.
The first rule of queer
club is that everyone's
in charge of their
own labels, OK?
No matter how much
someone else thinks
you don't fit that
definition, it doesn't matter.
Because this is how
people live and love.
You can't pin it down.
It is all gray area.
There is nothing
black and white.
This is all a continuum.
There is nothing
specific here other
than people's lived
experiences, and you just
don't get to argue
with those, OK?
So everyone is in charge
of their own labels.
So some people might
identify as transsexual,
and that is absolutely fine.
The reason why
people don't like it
anymore is because
it's quite medically.
It's such a focus on
the medical aspect
of being trans, which
doesn't apply to everybody.
Not everyone wants to medically
transition or even consider
that to be an OK term to use.
So yeah, we don't
really use it anymore.
So go forth and
don't use, please.
And it comes from this idea that
your sex is your gender, right?
So that's not true.
Sex and gender are
very separate things.
Sex is a series of
biological traits,
and gender is [MUMBLES].
I don't fully know.
That's why there's
college departments called
gender studies.
I guess they haven't
figured it out.
So I don't know.
Gender is like a
social construct
that's different from culture
to culture and depending on what
time you're in.
But seems to be innate in
most people about the gender
that they are.
This is complex.
I can't cover this
all in this workshop.
But the idea that it's
connected to your sex
is this concept called
bioessentialism.
And if you're leveling
up, more woke, going up
the triangle of wokeness,
this is the type of thing
you can say casually at a party.
You can be like, I'm just
against bioessentialism.
And then leave.
Just leave straight away.
You don't want to stay after
you say that in case someone
knows more than you.
Because this has happened to me.
Someone's there,
like, an expert.
And I'm like, oh, shit.
I just want to sound smart.
So yeah, bioessentialism
is this idea
that your biology is essential
to your gender, and it is bad.
It's not a cool thing.
Right.
Q.
AUDIENCE: Queer.
BELLA FITZPATRICK: Yay.
Does anybody feel like
you can't use the word
"queer" if you're not LGBT?
A little nod, little
nod, some people?
But most of you feel like
it's grand to use it?
Cool.
Well, I speak for
all LGBT people.
And yeah, it is fine.
It's fine to use.
Absolutely.
Not everyone would
agree with me there.
Not everyone is going to agree
with everything I say here.
The reason why it's fine to use
is because it's a descriptor.
It describes things.
Yes, it's a pejorative term
reclaimed by a minority group.
And like other pejorative terms
reclaimed by minority groups,
you've no business using those.
But this one, you do, because it
is a way to be more inclusive.
So rather than saying "gay"
as a collective term, which
is not OK, you say "queer"
as a collective term.
So I'm bisexual.
And therefore, if you
were to say later,
I had a talk by a gay
woman about gay issues,
that would not be true.
None of that would be true.
It wouldn't make
any sense to say.
But you could say I had
a talk by a queer woman
about queer issues.
Queerness is what connects
everybody in the community.
Not everyone identifies that
way, because rule number one,
everyone's in charge
of their own labels.
But most people do of
the younger generation,
and most people we talk to in
schools do identify that way.
So say I'm a bisexual
woman, Julian's a gay man,
but what connects us
is we're both queer.
Yeah.
That's like, the
multiple Venn diagram
of all these identities,
the very middle bit--
that's queer.
So yeah, go forth
and use if you want.
I?
AUDIENCE: Intersex.
BELLA FITZPATRICK: Intersex.
Very good, yeah.
So this is where we don't
love exact definitions.
But I guess with intersex,
it can be quite handy.
So it's having sexual
characteristics
not typically associated with
being either male or female.
So this is where lots
of people think of sex
as being a binary concept--
men over here, women over here--
penises, vaginas--
nothing in the middle.
All penises in one
box, and all vaginas--
oh, sorry.
That was gross, sorry.
Yeah, and there is
space in between.
There is different
ways to have biology.
And they don't fall into a
certain pattern all the time.
And if that's the way you
are, then you're intersex.
And it's not a birth defect.
It's not an abnormality.
It's the way skin
color and hair color
vary between individuals, so
do characteristics of sex.
So this would also
be an argument
against bioessentialism.
So that's really good to know.
Just back on queer for a second.
When I said that
it's more inclusive,
that allows you to sidestep
an issue called gaywashing.
This is where a
gay man washes you.
No.
It's not that.
This is where you use
gay as a collective term,
and it's very difficult
and problematic
for the rest of the community.
I don't know if you noticed, but
G is actually just one letter.
There's a bunch of others.
And this brings us to a
problem with this acronym being
actually a little limiting.
It doesn't really
serve us that well,
because it's very front-loaded
with the most represented
identities.
And if people's
attention span is
kind of front loaded as well,
and then you kind of trail off,
then you're losing some of the
least represented identities
as you go down the line.
So it can be a limiting acronym.
Great brand, though.
Everyone recognizes it, so
you have to balance the two.
OK.
A.
AUDIENCE: Ally?
BELLA FITZPATRICK: No.
Asexual.
Yeah.
Yeah, absolutely.
Asexual.
If you wanted, controversially,
to put in Ally,
you'd have to put in another A.
AUDIENCE: Two As, [? right? ?]
BELLA FITZPATRICK: Two As, yeah.
We don't, because allies are
a guest in this community, not
a member of this community.
And that's very important.
That's not to limit the
incredible, amazing things
that our allies
have done for us.
But yeah, they're not really
part of the community.
So when we do this in schools,
and we say, what's asexual?
Normally, the kids
say, and that's
when a strawberry
mates by itself
to make another strawberry.
And we're like, yeah.
I don't know.
Made it to the
community somehow.
No, of course not.
This is when you don't
experience sexual attraction
to other people.
So very similar coming
out story to LGB
where you get to a certain age,
people are talking about sex.
Say, if you're a gay
guy in a group of lads,
and everyone's talking
about sex with women.
And you're like,
ooh, no, thank you.
It's like that, but you're
like, ooh, no, thank you
for all sex with other people.
That doesn't mean they
won't have sex necessarily,
but they don't experience
that sexual desire.
They might want to be romantic.
They might have a
romantic attraction.
So you could be
asexual, but romantic.
And within being asexual, you
could be asexual biromantic,
panromantic, heteroromantic,
homoromantic--
so it's a whole thing.
Yeah.
Very under-represented,
though-- very under-represented.
Does anybody watch "Riverdale?"
Yes?
OK.
I mean, it's just
terrible, isn't it?
Yes, but it's great.
It's awful.
It's brilliant.
Yeah, yeah.
So that's based on
a graphic novel.
And in the graphic novel, one
of the characters is asexual,
but when they put it
on Netflix, he's not.
Jughead-- and he's
hypersexual, yeah.
Yeah.
So that would be
disappointing, wouldn't it
be, if you were asexual?
And you were, like, oh,
represent-- oh, never mind.
Yeah.
So P.
AUDIENCE: Pansexual.
BELLA FITZPATRICK: Pansexual, of
course, an attraction to pans.
One day, I'm just not going
to clarify after I say that.
Yeah.
So I mean, I can say that
because I'm bisexual.
You can't say that.
Don't make that joke.
That's not part of your
woke hierarchy thing.
So pansexual is a
brilliant term for people
who feel it reflects
them better than bisexual
because there is a common
misconception that bisexuality
means that you're
attracted to men and women.
I'm sure that's probably
what you thought bisexual
was on your way in here today.
It's not.
It hasn't meant that
in a long, long time.
So "bisexual" was coined in
1873 or something like that.
And of course, that's
what it meant back then.
But for a long time,
the bisexual community
is considered the
binary aspect of it,
linguistically, to mean your
own gender and other genders.
So I'm attracted to women
and people of other genders.
So it's inclusive of the many
genders we have in the world.
But because most
people don't know that,
you might be uncomfortable
identifying that way
and having people misconstrue
what you mean by that.
So pansexual is a
great way to reject
gender binaryism-- this
idea that there's only
men and women.
That's another term
for the party, right?
I just reject gender
binaryism-- and then leave.
The leaving is important.
And pansexual-- because
"pan" means all, right?
"Bi" means two, "pan"
means all-- like panorama.
All of the rama.
I just don't know, don't
know what that means.
So it's kind of a newer term.
If you take Google Trends that
kind of came up in around 2007.
There's a lot of overlap
between the two identities.
So one way you
could think about it
is that pan people are gender
blind when it comes to picking
a sexual or romantic partner.
But there's no animosity
between the two groups.
We're friends.
No dance-offs or
anything like that.
All right.
And plus?
AUDIENCE: [? Anything ?]
[? else. ?]
BELLA FITZPATRICK:
Anything else.
Absolutely, yeah.
Could not possibly cover it all.
Anything else-- a lot
of other identities
fall under these
umbrella identities here.
So, say, genderfluidity
or nonbinary-- most people
consider that to
fall under trans.
Because trans simply means that
you were assigned incorrectly
at birth.
That's what it means.
It's not about being in the
wrong body, nothing like that.
Try to steer away from
that type of rhetoric.
It means you were assigned
incorrectly at birth.
So what I mean is, you
got born, remember?
And a midwife looks at you
or a doctor looks at you
and decides on your
external genitalia
whether you're a boy or girl.
And this works out just really
well for a lot of people,
like 98% of people,
this works out well
because they also identify
with that same way.
And they feel comfortable within
that role that's in society.
Or they might not feel
comfortable in the role,
but they still
identify that way.
And this is called
being cisgender, OK?
So if you were assigned
correctly at birth,
you're cisgender.
Comes from Latin, means
"on the same side."
So "cis" means "on
the same side."
"Trans" means "on
the other side."
So you know trans fats?
Yeah.
That's when the hydrogen atom's
on the other side of the carbon
chain.
That's the only time I
use my chemistry degree--
four years for that sentence.
So yeah, if you were
assigned correctly at birth,
you were cisgender.
If you were assigned
incorrectly at birth,
you were transgender, OK?
So for every word of
something in the community,
there's a word for
everything that's not that.
And that just allows us to
use more appropriate language
than saying normal or
something like that,
which would not be as ideal.
But as I say, it's
very front-loaded.
So there are other options.
So QUILTBAG-- yeah?
It's another acronym.
It's also the name of
my knitting circle.
OK.
So I think we've done
all of these letters
except for U. Anybody
know what U is?
AUDIENCE: [? Unsure? ?]
BELLA FITZPATRICK: Yeah.
Unsure.
Yeah, exactly.
Undecided.
Yeah, curious, that type of
thing-- unsure, undecided.
This just allows us to
think about these letters
in a different way.
Because linguistics
is really important.
And the fact that we
front-load LGBT all the time
does actually impact how you
think about the community.
So if you just mix it
up, that's really great.
There are other ways,
as well, though.
MOGAI.
All right.
Let's see what you know here.
M?
I'm only joking.
You wouldn't know it.
So it stands for
Marginalized Orientations,
Gender Alignments,
and Intersex people.
OK.
Marginalized orientations,
gender alignments,
and intersex people.
So marginalized orientations are
not heterosexual orientations.
Marginalized gender
alignments are
when you're gender assigned
at birth does not correspond
to who you actually are.
And intersex people
are intersex people.
So it's kind of is a nice
way to cover everybody.
That make sense?
Another one for
the party, right?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
BELLA FITZPATRICK:
Beautiful question.
Really good question about--
people say this a lot,
being gay is not the same
thing as being trans.
Yeah, OK.
Why we do this is because
all of the LGBT community
fall under not the
assumption of the norm.
That is what binds us.
So when you're born, you get
assigned a label at birth.
People expect you to
identify that way,
and people expect you
to behave that way.
And part of that
behavior is that you
will like the opposite sex, OK?
So this all falls under a
line of assumed identities,
of all of which the
LGBT community are not.
There is unbelievable
similar experiences
between people who are LGB
and people who are TQIAP.
It's also about autonomy, right?
Right to self-identify, right
to decide your own labels--
and we all struggle under that.
So we are all united
by this otherness,
this marginalization.
And the LGBT rights movement was
started by trans women of color
who were sex workers.
And that's a really
important point.
At no point was T
tacked on anywhere.
Maybe in the
marketing department,
who I've yet to meet,
of the LGBT community--
I need to have a chat with them.
But at no point did
it get tacked on.
It was always the one community.
Because for a long
time, it was so taboo.
And it would just mean
your instant death
if you came out as trans.
So that's where you have
ideas around drag culture
where there's a lot of drag
queens were actually trans.
Now we can think about them
as very separate identities.
But at the beginning,
that was always
in the gay bars, that was
always with the lesbians,
that was always with the bi
people, the queer people,
the people who didn't get to
decide how they were assigned
at birth, because
they had genitalia
that looked like none of
the above options, which
is male or female.
And they had unnecessary
cosmetic surgery
done on them as babies.
And that falls under
the line of not
being allowed to
identify yourself
and not having the autonomy.
So what connects us
all is this experience.
We are all connected
in this way.
Yes.
We have different experiences.
I have a different experience
from a trans woman.
from an intersex person.
I have a different experience
from an asexual person.
But I have more similar
experiences with them
than I do with cis,
straight people.
So hopefully that
answers a little bit.
OK.
So this is what we're trying
to get people to care about.
And there's a few principles.
Learning is easier
than unlearning.
OK, so learning
something from nothing
is way easier than undoing
social conditioning, which is
what we have to do in ShoutOut.
You can't be right,
but you can be wrong.
This is the shit,
but this is true.
Not everything I've said
here today will be right.
It has been updated
since we walked in.
We are constantly evolving.
And again, it's all gray area.
So you can't be right
about your definitions.
You can't be right about your
understanding of other people's
experiences.
But you can be super wrong.
You could say it in the wrong
way that really excludes
a lot of people, or you can
say it in the most updated way.
But you're never right, OK?
Just bear that in mind.
I'm not right right now.
No one's right.
You can only be right
about your own experiences.
And then knowing is
not the same as caring.
And this is key, OK?
Being an ally is not about
knowing your LGBTQIAs
from your MOGAIs,
your trans demi guys
from your asexual
heteroromantics.
It's not about that.
It's about not making
assumptions and taking people's
life experiences at face value.
But we have to come
up with different ways
to teach our
different audiences.
So we have our
student workshops.
We have our teachers,
parents, guardians, youth
workers workshops.
And we have other adults--
you are other adults--
corporates, right?
Other adults-- something
like medical professionals
are other adults--
that type of thing.
And we have a different
tactic for each one.
This is basically manipulation.
Different forms.
So in the student workshop,
we use social norm theorem.
This is where you
present a change
that you want to see as
having already happened.
It's used in the States
a lot for things like--
they'll have signs
up in college being
like, "80% of people
who go out drinking
have a big meal beforehand."
And that's just not true, right?
But then people are like, oh,
that's the normal thing to do.
I'll do that.
So we kind of present
LGBT acceptance
as being the norm, that
if you want to get on well
in your workplace,
you should try
to be accepting and celebratory
of other identities,
be they LGBT or otherwise,
and that this has happened.
It is lies.
But look, there you go.
So our workshop with students,
because we go into schools
and we're not teachers,
we have to, first of all,
authoritize ourselves.
I actually don't think
that's a word, but look.
And we do that by creating
a contract just up
on the whiteboard in school.
And we say, can we all
agree that we'll be sound,
that we'll be confidential
if anybody says anything,
and that we don't
talk out of turn?
And that just kind of puts
you in a authoritative stance.
And then you have
to humanize yourself
by giving your own
personal coming out
story or your personal story
on your journey as an ally.
Then we educate them by telling
them the definitions for LGBT.
We get them to practice their
empathy by putting themselves
in the idea of other people's
shoes or other people's
positions.
We put that into practice
in scenario groups.
So we put them into groups
and decide, what would you
do if your friend came out?
What would you do if
you witnessed bullying?
And then we empower them
by letting them come up
with the next agenda
for how they're
going to make their school
an LGBT-inclusive place.
And this is key--
so important.
This is really important
that kids feel ownership
over the culture
of their school.
The school is not four
walls that they walk into.
They are the school.
And even if it's
just in their class
or their group of
friends, they can
make an LGBT-inclusive bubble.
And they have the
power to do that.
So this is a really
important point.
Any suggestions they make,
we feedback to the school.
And this is where we find out
a lot of troubling things,
such as kids not
being able to bring
same-sex dates to
the dance, girls
not being able to have hair
shorter than their shoulder,
trans kids being forced to
wear the uniform that they're
uncomfortable in.
And we get to feed that
back to the schools
and hopefully see some change.
Then with teachers, parents,
guardians, and youth workers,
gently does it, OK?
They already care a shit ton.
That is the technical term.
They are there because
they care so, so much.
I have never really had to
get a teacher on-site caring
about the well-being
of their students,
even if they disagree with me,
even if they think everything
I say is liberal hogwash,
they still really care.
And if you keep on
bringing it back to,
oh, our only goal here is
kids not killing themselves,
then they get on board
with you pretty quickly,
even if they don't agree with
the methods you've suggested.
So we like to reassure them.
This is solvable.
These are solvable problems--
a few steps, you'll be grand.
Educate them, put
it in practice,
and empower them to
go forward-- so kind
of similar to the student
workshop in a lot of ways.
And then other adults--
different, right?
We use intellectualization to
make you value the concepts,
OK?
That's the idea here.
Because most of the time,
when we're doing other adults,
we're doing corporates.
Most people who work in
corporates go to college.
We have a value system
around higher ideas,
and we just exploit
that by making
it seem like a difficult thing
to get your head around so then
you will value it.
The main issue we
have with corporates
is that people come
to seminars and think,
I am going to be
patronized by someone
who's going to tell me
to be nice to gay people.
And I know to be
nice to gay people.
So we need to make sure
that they know that it
is more in-depth than that.
They are going to
learn something.
It is going to be interesting.
They are going to be able to
use it at a party and walk away.
So the first thing we need
to do is horrify them, OK?
This is the first step--
get them to care.
And that's where
we bring in stats
like three times more attempted
suicide by LGBT young people
compared to their cis,
straight counterparts, twice
as much self-harm, and four
times the amount of depression,
stress, and anxiety.
Get them to care.
Get them to realize,
post-marriage equality,
we have not solved everything.
Then we soothe them.
It's OK.
It's OK, corporates.
It'll be all right.
That, there are
things we can do.
There's an action plan.
There's an agenda.
It'll be fine.
Then we engaged them
with complex theories.
Bamboozle them.
And then we horrify them
again so they leave,
and they want to do something.
That's when we talk about the
unnecessary "normalization"
surgeries done on intersex
young people, which
is the next big thing for the
LGBT community in Ireland,
just to stop these.
And they have been stopped
in other countries.
This is very behind
the curtain, guys.
I feel a little uncomfortable
that you know all my tactics
now, but look.
So how we go about
intellectualizing it is,
rather than explaining
each letter in a definition
in a silo, we consider
them as falling somewhere
on a series of spectra, OK?
And this is really important
because everyone's reflected
in these, not just LGBT people.
Straight, cis people are
reflected in these, too.
And once you can see
yourself in something,
suddenly, you care about
it a little bit more.
So I'm not going to go
through the full whack of what
we do, because it
takes about two hours,
and the sun is shining,
so I won't do that.
But this is just a general
idea of what it looks like.
So we do this on a flip
chart on a white board.
It's very organic.
We never really do
it on PowerPoint.
Because I think there's,
like, a Pavlovian response
to PowerPoint, which
is to fall asleep.
So I'm apologizing if
this is happening now.
But we consider these
spectras like sexuality,
sexual orientation, gender
expression, gender identity,
and biological sex--
all of them fall on a spectra.
Some of them need to be a
triangle because there's ideas
outside our binary concepts.
But we lure them into a
false sense of security
first by having them
just straight lines,
and then we add
the triangle later.
And they're like, oh, no.
They'll be OK, though.
The first thing we
do is differentiate
sexuality from sexual
orientation because, of course,
these are different.
But people use them
interchangeably a lot.
The reason we like
to differentiate them
is that we're not talking
about sexuality in schools.
It doesn't come up.
It doesn't happen.
And people use it to deny
our access in schools.
They say, I don't
just don't think
you should be talking
about sexuality in schools.
What does that possibly
got to do-- this
is every mother's accent.
What does that possibly
got to do with school?
And they're there
to learn and blah.
So we say, well,
we're not doing that,
because sexuality is different
than sexual orientation.
Sexuality is how much you like
sex, the type of sex you like,
the frequency of the sex.
Sexual orientation
is with whom you
might want to have that sex.
So when we talk to
young people, we
talk about sexual orientation--
more often than not,
romantic orientation.
We don't talk about sexuality.
We do in the corporates, if
you ever want to book one,
talk about sexuality.
But I guess the important
point around sexuality
is just how much we
moralize sex, right?
So asexual people--
they get extremely
discriminated against,
saying, you don't have sex?
You're weird then.
Or you haven't met
the right person.
You don't know your body.
Or you're not being
sex positive enough.
All this really annoying
rhetoric for them,
which denies them
their right to be
in charge of their own
label, rule number one.
So you can consider
sex positivity
to be a movement
that is about being
comfortable with any
amount of sex you're
having because no one is.
There's too little sex,
and you should feel bad
about that, because
you're a loser.
You're not having sex.
And there's too much sex.
You should feel bad
about that because you're
a little slut, right?
And then there's this
perfect amount of sex
that you can feel good
about having, and no one
knows what it is.
So we all just feel
bad all of the time.
Welcome to Ireland.
So we like to talk
about this a little bit
and get people to realize
that, as long as you're
comfortable and
consensual and happy,
and that's all that matters.
And there's a couple of ways
you can talk about these issues.
You can build on ideas that
people already have, build it
up, blocky blocky, or you
can flip the idea on its head
and go with the most complicated
issue first and build down.
And this is where we have our
pyramid of queer concepts.
So at the bottom, love is love.
Isn't love grand?
Love knows no gender.
Love is love.
Everyone knows this.
Most people accept this.
If people don't
accept this, they're
not really going to get on
board with a lot of what
I'm saying anyway.
I don't know why they
came to my workshop.
So yeah, love is love.
Tout it around a lot.
I absolutely despise it,
but that's another workshop.
Love is not love.
People are people,
and love isn't love.
That's their takeaway
message from this talk.
But it's a really
good place to start
because people, in general,
accept that love is love
and that love is grand.
You do you.
That is my general way of saying
people can express themselves
however they like.
Men can wear nail varnish-- ooh.
Women can be butch--
that type of thing.
A little less people
accept that, but more
than the next thing,
which is everyone is
in charge of their own label.
People don't like that.
People love gatekeeping.
They love it.
It's their favorite thing.
So if you, say,
had a gay man who
sleeps with multiple genders,
sleeps with women very often,
people would love to deny
them that they're gay.
But they're in charge
of their own label.
Now, are they not using
the label bisexual because
of the stigma around
being bisexual?
Maybe.
Probably.
Let's work on that stigma.
Let's not chastise the
person for the label they've
chosen, OK?
Everyone's in charge
of their own label.
We get people to accept that,
then they have less of a
back and forth about, but
if you're this, and then
how can you be that if--
and we're like, well, everyone's
in charge of their own label.
Sex isn't the same as gender.
Way less acceptance
around this because we
like to interchange--
twist it all up a lot.
But when you kind of get into
the concepts and the idea
that there's always been
third genders in society
since record in every
anthropological study ever.
Every society has found third
genders-- that's male, female,
and third genders.
In Native American culture,
it's called being two-spirited.
In Southeast Asia, it's
called being hijra.
The Maori have
their own version.
That's been around for
a very, very long time,
and that is not
connected to sex--
sex being a set of
biological traits.
So when people
don't accept this,
they're being bioessentialist.
But you can get a
lot of people there.
Gender isn't binary.
That's a little bit
trickier because we've
been touting this--
men and women, the men
and women of this country.
And all the forms
say male and female.
There is no other option.
There might be
options on cool forms,
but not government forms.
Eventually, you might get
people to accept down in the
"you do you."
You kind of bring that up
and say, well, ultimately,
what does it take away from you?
And if you have to
go down that route,
it's not ideal,
because we are trying
to aim a little bit higher
than tolerance-- trying to aim
for acceptance and celebration.
But sometimes, you have
to settle for tolerance.
You can't do this
and be a purist.
It just wouldn't work.
So you have to put all
your woke ideals aside
because you have
to bridge that gap.
And that's what we're doing.
We are standing in between
the two communities
and bridging the
gap as best we can.
And then either is sex--
that's the toughest one.
Sex isn't binary, either.
There's all these other
traits you can have.
There's different
ways to be a person.
You can have
ambiguous genitalia.
That's a terrible
term, but it's what is
used in the medical industry.
You can have XY chromosomes
normally, typically
associated with being male,
but you can have XY chromosomes
and have a vagina.
And this happens.
It's not something I've made up.
And in that case, is that
person male or female?
We don't know.
What is being male or female?
It's all a series of
spectrums and different ways
of looking at things.
We like to think about
it as very, very strict.
And that's because
it's easy to teach kids
about strict ideas that
fall into certain boxes.
That is an easy way
to think about things.
But if you study biology
at a higher level,
you realize that most of
biology is people being
like, [MUMBLES], I don't know.
It's all very weird.
I don't know.
And that's very confronting
for people to not feel
like they know the truth and
that they've been lied to.
And you haven't
lied to every time
you've been told there's
only men and women.
You haven't been lied to.
You just haven't been
told the full truth, OK?
And that's OK.
So you can either build up, or
you can flip it on its head,
start with the fact the
biological sex is not binary,
and move downwards.
Because if biological sex
isn't binary, what is gender?
What is sex?
Who does it care
who you love, yeah?
You can go that way.
So it's one way or another.
And it's all about the
audience that you're with,
the type of people they are,
and the tactic you think
is going to work on the day.
So you decide at the time.
So I'm very uncomfortable
that you know all my secrets.
Now, I would like to ask
if you have any queries.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
This is a bad idea.
AUDIENCE: Go.
AUDIENCE: Thanks
very much for that.
I thought it was really
interesting and insightful.
I had a question
about, I guess, what
you're describing as people are
in charge of their own labels.
And there's a lot of
challenges to that, too.
You keep brushing up against the
limits of self-definition from
parents saying, oh,
it's just a phase to--
I don't know-- jokes
going around like, oh, you
can identify as another gender.
Well, I'll identify as a chair.
Ha-ha.
BELLA FITZPATRICK: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And how do
you respond to that?
What's your tactic for that?
BELLA FITZPATRICK: The classic
one we get on the internet
is, I identify as an
attack helicopter.
I don't know.
All the anti-trans
people had a meeting
and decided that was
the funniest thing
to say you identify as.
So yeah, we get that a lot.
And I guess there's a
lot to unpack there.
I'm bisexual, so I've had a
lot of, that's just a phase.
I've had a lot of that.
Now, I came out at nine.
I am now 28.
It is a long phase.
But so what if it was?
Ultimately, so what?
Should we be such
gatekeepers, or should we
leave that door open?
And should we allow people to
explore their gender identities
and their sexuality and their
sexual orientation and all
these-- and their gender
expression, as well?
I think we should be far
more fluid about these things
because that allows
people to not
have to be so sure before
they say anything about it.
And that pent-up
anxiety is where
we have what's called
minority stress, the fact
that you're in a minority group
being a stressful experience
even before you experience
any sort of discrimination.
So I just think the answer to
this is to not care as much.
But that doesn't mean you
get away with not knowing
how to be respectful.
Those two things
aren't the same.
Just saying I don't care
how people identify,
that's not helpful.
We should all care about what
makes someone comfortable
and what makes someone's
movement through this world
easier, especially when
what we're asked to do
is so easy on our behalf.
Ask people's
pronouns, not assume
if they're straight or gay or bi
or whatever, not slagging them
for what they wear.
These are really
simple things to do.
It's like the way
buildings are accessible.
That's an easy way to make
some people's life-- are they
in the minority?
Yeah.
Does that mean we
shouldn't care about them?
No.
So I don't think there's any
limits to self-identification.
The question is, what
does that mean you're
asking other people to do?
If you're saying, I
identify as nonbinary,
or genderfluid, what are you
asking other people to do?
You're asking them to
use maybe a name that
isn't on their birth
cert and pronouns
that you might
have not heard of,
like "they" and "them" or
"ze" and "zem" or something
like that.
If you identify as
an attack helicopter,
what are you asking
people to do?
Are you asking them to
have a helicopter landing
pad for their work?
Maybe you are.
I don't know.
But if it's something I can
do, I'll actually do it.
I don't care if that's
how you identify.
But you're just being
facetious when people say that.
Of course they are.
But the way to counteract
that obvious, ridiculous claim
is to be accepting.
Kill them with kindness, as
my granddad would always say.
What can they come back as you
with if you say, oh, you're
an attack helicopter?
Right, so what pronouns
do you use, though?
That's the answer.
Thanks for the question.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
BELLA FITZPATRICK: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Do you have a way
to reach people that are not
in school and not in corporate?
BELLA FITZPATRICK: Yeah.
So we do a lot of works
with youth groups and scouts
or early school
leavers, as well.
But we have now started to talk
about-- this is my colleague
Clare.
We've started talking about
having open meetings for people
who want this information.
Important to note, though, that
we're not an LGBT organization
for LGBT youths.
We're not youth workers.
So we don't have, like, come to
our cafe and be LGBT with us.
Because there are
other places that
do and do that really, really
well, such as BeLonG To.
We're there for people who
just want to be educated.
We're a training organization.
So we are going to have more
open training, say, parents
bring your kids and
that type of thing.
So yeah, we're going to move
towards more events like that.
Absolutely.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: Hey.
Great talk, first of all.
I was wondering-- so
in my personal life,
I think I see more
and more of resistance
against trans
inclusivity, especially,
from within the LGBT community,
paradoxically, like TERFs,
specifically.
And I wanted to ask, have you
run into these people at all?
Or do you feel you
run into them more?
BELLA FITZPATRICK: Oh, yes.
Does everybody know
what TERF means?
Trans Exclusionary
Radical Fuckers.
The F actually stands
for Feminists, sorry.
Trans Exclusionary
Radical Feminists.
It's just a misnomer because
they're not feminist.
This is this movement which
is bioessentialist, eh?
Which is this idea that you
can't just throw on a dress
and be a woman, because
at the end of the day,
you have a penis, and
you have XY chromosomes,
and that's all
there is to it, OK?
That's the type of
rhetoric TERFs will use.
It's very troublesome.
We don't have as many in Ireland
as there seems to be in the UK.
I don't really know why that is.
Really, feminists you
would have respected
have this stance, such as
Germaine Greer, although, I
don't think anybody's respected
her in a long while, right?
I haven't.
So she's a massive TERF.
Now, it coming from
within the community
is so hurtful and confusing.
And I think that's got to do
with a certain marginalization
of our lesbian community
not being as embraced
by the wider LGBT community,
even though they're
the first letter.
They should get all--
they should be as
front-loaded as possible.
And so they kind of
veered off and then
were kind of worried about
their spaces being incringed on.
It is very worrisome.
And I have large, large
arguments with them on Twitter.
And I would not recommend
this if you enjoy being happy
or like having any free time.
I actually would not
recommend Twitter at all
if you enjoy those two things.
The key here is
to really rip off
their mask of what
they are presenting,
which is this terribly
polite, just wanting
to have a conversation piece.
That's what they always say.
There's this group in the UK
called Woman's Place UK who
are an anti-trans organization.
They're a hate organization.
They've created a
document that looks
like it's trans-inclusive
for teachers
that is just hate-filled,
and that is despicable.
They have all this rhetoric
around just being very, very
polite.
And ultimately, when you
are a marginalized group,
you don't care about politeness.
You don't care about Ps and Qs.
You care about
systematic oppression,
and they are holding that up.
So I don't care if they had tea
and biscuits at their meeting.
They're a hate group.
They're a hate organization.
So if you get them to
reveal that by pushing ever
so slightly, get
them to take off
that mask-- because a lot
of times, they're like,
we're just having a meeting.
It's freedom of speech.
There was tea and biscuits.
I can't believe all this
outrage that there is.
Can't women meet and have
tea and biscuits anymore?
And you're like,
yeah, cool, you can.
But not when your whole
purpose of your organization
is to marginalize a
very marginalized group.
And they conveniently
ignore the statistics
around how vulnerable
trans people are.
The average life expectancy
of a trans woman of color
in the United States is 35.
35, OK?
You're talking
about 1% of people.
They are not a threat to you.
If you're talking
about bathrooms, right?
People should act
appropriately in bathrooms--
the end, OK?
You should not know about
other people's genitalia
in a bathroom, because if--
they're using the bathroom
wrong if you found out
about their genitalia.
That's essentially it.
So I really like
to push them on it.
So then their mask
slips a little bit.
So then people on
the periphery who
are sort of seeing their point
are like, oh, you're just hate.
You're actually just hate.
You have a nice facade, but
you're actually just hate.
And that allows you to get more
people to realize the bigger
picture here.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
BELLA FITZPATRICK:
One at the very back.
AUDIENCE: I can speak
to that because I
was a student teacher.
I was at an event last week
where there was a children's
art competition and was run--
I like what you
said about, I belong
to the [? ING ?] LGBT group.
BELLA FITZPATRICK: Yeah.
Fantastic group.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
And I feel confident,
and that gives me courage
as well, you know?
By removing off the
hating of the trans--
I heard this dreadful
story at the meeting,
at that awards ceremony,
where-- now, I wonder,
am I saying this--
a child, a five-year-old
child with a penis
came to school dressed with
a dress on with its mommy.
BELLA FITZPATRICK:
Their mommy, yeah.
AUDIENCE: And standing by
said, beat that out of him.
BELLA FITZPATRICK: Aw, Jesus.
AUDIENCE: And so that
mother was distressed,
and the school principal
was distressed.
And they don't know want
to do about that situation.
So I think, yeah, I just
wanted to-- this is,
on the ground, what happens.
Now, particularly, [INAUDIBLE]
at schools, more children
can present as they
want to present.
BELLA FITZPATRICK: Mm-hmm.
Yeah, that's such a
troubling, but unfortunately,
common story.
TENI just recently published
a report on gender norms
in primary schools,
which is very
troubling about how much we
force kids into gender norms.
And this young child who might
be trans or might like dresses,
you know?
Those aren't necessarily
the same thing,
and both should be accepted.
Ultimately, parents have a
right to raise their kid however
they want, but not
within child abuse.
And forcing your child
to express themselves
in a way that causes them
distress is child abuse.
And we need to recognize
that and be more confident
in our place in the right, OK?
So we deal with schools
where parents have said,
my kid's going through
a bit of a phase.
They're using
they/them pronouns.
I'd really appreciate it
if you didn't indulge.
And we want teachers to
know they have the right
to say, well, actually, whatever
you do in your own house--
but in this school, we'll
respect the young person
because young
people have rights.
Young people have autonomy.
And they are allowed to petition
the school board with regards
to this.
And they are allowed to go
to the children's ombudsman
if they are unsatisfied.
Because under the Equal
Status Act of 2015,
continuous purposeful
use of incorrect pronouns
can be considered harassment.
So we shouldn't allow
what we consider
to be personal preference
on how you raise
your kids to allow child abuse.
So that's what I would
say in that instance.
I hope that kid is OK.
Thanks.
So should we stop?
SPEAKER 1: Clap
her again, please.
[APPLAUSE]